hallo mein name ist luca heute bin ich
allerdings wieder
ich coache ich als normaler pokémon
trainer
bz ich bin ja heute wieder einstechen
ich hab mir gedacht okay pokémon go hier
in deutschland zu spielen ist natürlich
schön allerdings ist es cooler wenn man
dafür nach london fahren würde
wir sind jetzt hier in london angekommen
meine damen und herren wir sehen schon
hier über alles london
ich habe wieder meinen pokal mit dabei
und wir versuchen jetzt hier einfach mal
in dem heutigen video irgendwie ein
coach klopp zusehen oder lock modul zu
installieren dort die nächste
wir laufen jetzt auf jeden fall ein
bisschen rum versuchen pokémon gefangen
haben wir schon bei ältere pokémon
gesehen hier vorne jetzt im fokus auf
meine damit hätte ich bin übrigens auch
schon david c also ich hab grad 2440 ep
von 10.000 brauche ich für das nächste
level
wir sind jetzt im hyde park angekommen
meine damen und herren
schön wenn babys ein
ich befinde mich gerade in broken go und
deswegen meine freunde wir hätten jetzt
am pokals
poggenborg meine damen und herren wir
befinden uns hier jetzt gerade wirklich
im hyde park ich glaube ich habe es
jetzt wirklich schon oft genug gesagt
hey du sieht dass wir gerade im hyde
park aus wir sehen schon hier oben okay
es lädt gerade die ganze zeit hat jemand
ein lock modus
dr
irgendwie habe ich gerade die nachricht
bekommen dass hier ein ei von mir aus
stück das wir kriegen jetzt einfach mal
drauf gucken was in dem ein drin ist in
kappadokien
nimmst du ja
mein name ist
wir sind jetzt hier gerade wirklich nach
einem harten weg zwei minuten sind wir
gegangen gerade wir sind jetzt hier
gerade am luxford angekommen meine damen
und herren allerdings sieht ja so aus
also da machen tatsächlich leute gerade
yoga drin dachte da wären hoch und
trainer aber die produkte de ist hier
befinden wir uns gerade hier ist der
poker ist ob el kaeda wo die leute yoga
machen wir schnappen uns dass robbie
warum drücken meine damen und herren
stehen geblieben warum warum die aber
die sonst selten ist pokémon supporter
waren wieder ein junger nach kabul
da sind die leute hier haben hier vorne
das raubt meine damen und herren wir
versuchen mit einem zweiten versuch das
haupt zu fangen raubtiers empore ball
wird es diesmal gefahr
es ist schon wieder abgestützt meine
damen und herren es soll einfach nicht
sein
es ist einfach nicht möglich das lied
wirklich die ganze zeit also ich
verstehe die ganze bleibe baxmann
behalte deine umgebung im auge
wir haben gerade auseinander ball
gefunden ich glaube hier waren schon
andere pokémon trainer ich weiß nicht
wie viele hunde denen schon irgendwie
der schnauze halten aber pokémon geht
immer noch nicht welche am arsch wir
haben hier ein schmetterling ich
versuche den schmetterling zu fangen
hat nicht geklappt weil pokémon immer
noch anmeldungen fehlgeschlagen was soll
das denn dann geht man extra einheit
tagen da kommt die ganze zeit nur so ein
schwachsinn da wir jetzt hier wirklich
keinen erfolg haben so richtig was zu
sammeln von pokémon angeht und auf die
ganz wir haben halt wenig gerade keinen
erfolg gehabt mit dem jagen von pokémon
und auch mit dem fangen von hotspots und
pokerstars und alben pokémon gold wieder
irgendwelche serverprobleme ist er
bisher nicht das erst mal vorgekommen
deswegen fahren wir zurück ins hotel und
gucken einfach mal ob wir da neue
pokémon finden
wir sind jetzt selbst jedem hotelzimmer
steht bei mir gps-signal nicht gefunden
also irgendwie ist es schon wieder
irgendwie da und da das ganze jetzt
einerseits im park nicht richtig
geklappt hat und andererseits auch jetzt
hier im hotelzimmer
ich glaube dir ich mal davon aus setzt
sie wieder irgendwelche server probleme
haben gelegen typ gerade dahin kommen
deswegen würde ich an dieser stelle
jetzt einfach sagen freunde ich beende
hiermit das video wenn es euch
vielleicht trotzdem gefallen habe ich
mich immer eine bewertung freuen wenn
ihr bock drauf habe dass ich einfach mal
irgendwann wenn ich irgendwie wieder in
deutschland bin lockt module
installieren bei irgendeinem poggersdorf
und damit das schreibe ich euch auf den
lock module installiert kommt da allemal
halte meine beine jucken so unnormal von
diesem scheiße wenn ihr das sehen wollen
dann schreibt sie in die kommentare